now then let's uh just  uh look at some breaking news uh coming  from the middle east and uh health  officials in gaza  are saying that nine people have been  killed um  including three children they say and  many more injured  at a hospital in gaza and this follows  they say israeli attacks on  gaza and this all follows of course um  hamas saying that they had fired rockets  into  israel um seven of which according to  the israelis got  into the jerusalem area others landing  in southern israel  and this was in turn in response  say a hamas to israeli security forces  firing rubber tipped bullets and stun  grenades and  so forth much earlier today into  a mosque the al-aqsa mosque one of the  most sacred sites for  muslims so a lot of tit-for-tat action  going on  here in the middle east on what is a  very big  day